also do you think it's too late to start
a business in your 30s huge fan by the
way uh very important and no 30 is not
there's not an age that's late as long
as you can walk talk you have energy and
you're excited about a vision you can
start it at 60 years old I mean nowadays
we're living a long time
um but let me answer the first one too
there was a book I read about CEOs if
you want to know more about it if you
tweet me I'll get the link and I'll put
it out there for people to see it it
talks about like five quality CEOs need
uh that people have before they become
CEOs of Fortune 500 companies okay
qualities that they have before they
become Fortune 500 CEOs so guys that are
moving up in the company like all of a
sudden this guy was a 22 year working at
McDonald's now he's a CEO how did that
happen the number one quality that these
people have uh was a reliability
reliability you're on time you show up
you're Dependable you get things done if
you say you're gonna do something you do
it an element of reliability is loyalty
so in in the game of business especially
nowadays at breakfast with Tommy mottola
in um
in New York two days ago okay if you
don't know what Tommy watola is you know
Mariah Carey Talia Godfather Sony he
took Sony from 600 million a year to
eight billion dollars a year he signed
Michael Jackson he signed Hal Hall and
Oates I don't know if you know and
Hollow notes they wrote a song about him
wow if you know Holland knows
1975. the guy's a stud of a guy he's a
he's one of those top five heavyweights
in music industry uh is uh Tommy mottola
and he said Patrick
um one of the things when I built Sony
we built it with six killers that we had
he says the hardest thing about finding
Killers today Killers today are more for
sale than they were back in the days
back in the days there was such thing as
loyalty today somebody makes a better
offer they're gone they go to a
different place right he says but if you
can find guys that buy into the vision
long term and they're reliable and
they're Dependable figure out a way to
do whatever you can to take care of
those guys as well if they show their
quality let me add one thing to this
because it's so true about loyalty one
of the things that I always like saying
is sometimes at your best ability is
your availability we all know how you
have those type of people in your life
they're like they might not be the most
talented you ever see the uh the Simon
sinek uh who you trust versus skill uh
Matrix you ever seen that where they
interviewed what Navy Seals yeah of what
type of people you want to roll with the
people with the most skill or who you
trust the most right and it wasn't even
a question they would take trust over
skill any day of the week because you
can't buy trust loyalty availability so
there's you know back to the men out
here it's like you might not be the best
at what you do but if you keep showing
up day in and day out that's loyalty
right there that's just that's a sort of
a derivative of loyalty
um with Pat once the the opportunity
what do they say that uh uh luck is when
uh opportunity meets preparation hard
work yeah I moved to Dallas you're right
I had a so much stuff going on in Miami
I said he says what do you want to do I
said I'm just making myself 100
available I moved to Dallas the lovely
town of Addison night life in Dallas
like the freaking if you can't speak
soccer Yard House is insane okay okay
Walmart aisle 17 the best looking women
in and out burger on Beltline Road
forget about it now Walmart he's
trolling yeah man but I just made myself
100 available and that's what I think a
lot of young people need to do right now
is just understand who can you align
align with who can you make yourself
available to and don't don't
stop don't leave don't look for another
job don't take the easy way out don't
try to get clicks real quick don't try
to make easy money what do you what are
the things you always say easy money
comes with a fast money comes with slow
problems 100 million percent and it kind
of like we talked about with the with
the YouTubers it's play the long game so
we're all going to have ups and downs
but if you play the long game and if you
extrapolate not have a myopic View and
not look past 6 12 18 months going to
the Future five years down Road 10 years
down the road 20 years down the fricker
road where do you want to be that will
solve for your availability and your
loyalty it's funny because we talk all
the time me and Myron and one thing we
don't have is time in the game that's
all we're missing right now we got the
word ethic we are we're consistent and
as well we put up good value so just
imagine where you're going to be 10
years from now if you keep doing this
just imagine go there in your house
we just started but so just yeah I mean
it's a long game yeah yeah you know it's
the same thing that I talk about with
money is that you know at some point you
become one of the things I say with
money and same thing with status as a
man is that there's red light yellow
light green light most people are
starting off at red light what is red
light your paycheck to paycheck you're
drowning in debt you've got student debt
you got credit card debt at some point
you need to get to yellow light you save
that money you you build up a base of
budget a foundation next thing you know
your green light you're an investor but
that might take five years but everyone
wants to take the easy way out we have
the Bitcoin conference here every year
and all I'm doing is interviewing guys
who are taking the easy way I bought
Dogecoin I'm a millionaire now not so
fast homie so I'm here about an nft I
got a board ape or whatever it's like
yeah that didn't work out so good yeah
so it's a foundation and stay in the
beginning a solid
um some solid advice here in a nutshell
just means build good relationships with
people that mean or have value pretty
much one million I'll never forget one
thing more than anything and this is it
one of the things that's that you uh
talk about is Reinventing yourself we
all have to reinvent ourselves when I
started on Instagram and YouTube I was
just save that money save that money say
that that's my thing now I've evolved
I've I've learned from
you know the network that we've created
here but I'll never forget
um my 10th grade teacher said if there's
anything you remember from my class is
that access is power and I've always
valued that because all right what does
access mean access is who you're around
with who are you with you know they say
that you are the the combination of the
ten five people that you surround
yourself with the most I've constantly
tried to access power players and
network with them whether that was in
Miami nightlife whether that's in
finance I met Pat in the gym
11 years ago at this point
um South Beach podcasters business guys
and access is power I mean we we've sat
down with some pretty interesting people
in the last month I don't want to get
into that but
when you're around these people you you
just make yourself available I just did
an event at boxer gym right with the
owner Mateo and I could have got it for
free but you know what I wanted to
access you know what I'm gonna pay bro
full price coming about connection and
now what he told me is a bro listen man
this is such a good turnout whatever
that you want to have here I got you on
the house so I'll pay for Access I don't
care how much it costs bro I actually
wears that all the way bro so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]